you know what if you want to apologize
for something apologize for that
my eyes are burning
don't don't blame me haven't you heard
the mayor wants christmas to be three
times bigger this year that means three
times the lights three times the eggnog
three times the information needed
that was a good one
oh my goodness this is one of your
kidding things finally something you
said is actually funny
yeah i do kill a lot but no this is
actually three times bigger well you're
just gonna have a good time with this
aren't you i gotta say it's really nice
to see you laughing sorry i i can't hear
you i don't speak
oh you're a scream have a nice life
goodbye i'll see you later
this is our enemy you will want to
unwrap it
and
play with it
[Music]
but you must not
if you can get past the present the only
obstacle left is
the cookie
look at it in all its red sugary
splendor
no no no look at yourselves
discipline we must
[Music]
resist
today was
great
we did mean things and we did them in
style
max
you know the rules you sleep in your bed
and i sleep in
oh no no not you two i don't believe
this max did you teach him puppy eyes
fine this one time
[Music]
all this excess and nonsense it was all
about greed
about meaningless stuff that they didn't
even need
the grinch went to work
he scooped up the toys
he raced against time
he raced against joy
[Music]
he hit a few snags as he made his way
through
an angry orange cat
and a sleep walking whoa
thank you mommy
[Music]
how much i don't know about the grinch
okay yes i know i'm gonna do great
where does the grinch live
mount
mount crumpet what are the names of
cindy lou's brothers
i know they both start with the beat
brad and
brett no one's bean buster and bean
that's my kids names how many sizes too
small is the grinch's heart
two times too small two easy however
many sizes too small his heart there's a
very strong beating heart to this
there's a reason why he is
so lost
that's beautiful how would the grinch
handle stress whale sounds come on now
immersion therapy like just throwing
himself into the center of whoville
performing some form of martial art a
discipline like
jiu jitsu genius starts with the abs max
[Music]
prepare to have your mind blown
what brings out your inner grinch ah
traffic you know
tight shoes this is very uncomfortable
we don't have cereal in the morning if
you could invent one new christmas
tradition what would it be giving
presents to strangers
some say the grinch was born with a
heart two sizes too small what's your
weirdest body part my pinkies are not
straight
fingers are supposed to be straight my
ears are weird
okay describe the grinch in the nicest
way possible
that's not gonna happen uh um
i can't say like ugly or nasty well okay
so
hey i don't know i don't know
what gift would you give the grinch a
better attitude a big hug
it's a massive hug that was beautiful
[Music]
in here
[Music]
smile
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
come around
[Applause]
[Music]
you can feel you're watching something
really special
this skater may become the next great
name in figure skating
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't you bring me down
[Music]
illumination
[Music]
um
[Music]
if
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your is banana with us
[Music]
today we will do mean things and we will
do them in style
oh hello happy holidays
[Music]
what's this
hey excuse me are you getting that
[Music]
the grinch
[Music]
stop socializing now let's go in for a
look
watch out
christmas already
look at those greedy little gift
monsters
ready
[Music]
oh hey look it's me
[Music]
[Music]
you're a mean one
mr grinch
and checkmate
again
today we will do mean things and we will
do them in style
[Music]
this perfectly recreates the mating call
of the reindeer behold oh hey there
sorry little goat i was looking for a
rain
[Music]
ah
the grinch
[Music]
this is the loudest snow i've ever heard
in my life
fred
what are you
doing
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
merry christmas
[Music]
i'm going to steal
this is our enemy
no no we must
[Music]
go team
[Music]
this is the loudest snow i've ever heard
in my life
[Music]
santa then i need to get into character
[Music]
it's go time
[Music]
[Music]
is
max i'm promoting you you will guide my
sleigh tonight
what max
[Music]
max
you know the rules
you sleep in your bed and i sleep in
max did you teach him puppy eyes
fine
[Music]